Chris waters here with a gamespot news  update possible footage from a ps4  exclusive title from the Demon Souls and  Dark Souls developer has shown up online  for short videos show a variety of  environments and enemies from an  unconfirmed in development game being  created by from software tentatively  called project beast we get a glimpse of  the combat with the shotgun wielding  protagonist fighting a group of enemies  wielding torches and blades we also see  a fog gate reminiscent of from  software's earlier Souls games which  seems to be made out of ghosts or souls  or somesuch then we catch a short  glimpse of a boss the game is reportedly  being developed by from software in a  partnership with Sony Japan and the game  is expected to be a PlayStation 4  exclusive I think it's a pretty safe bet  we'll be seeing more about project beast  at e3 which is just about a week away so  stay tuned to gamespot  you